الى فرنسا حيث ينتظر ان يعلن المجلس
الدستوري قرره بشان مدى دستوريه قانون
التقاعد الجديد المثير للجدل بعد نحو شهر
من المداولات المغلقه وتعول النقابات
العماليه والاحزاب اليساريه المعارضه على
راي المجلس الدستوري لاسقاط القانون او
بعض بنوده على الاقل خصوصا نتعلق منها
برفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما كما سيعلن
المجلس عن رايه في طلب تقدمت به احزاب
يسريه معارضه يتمثل في مبادره مشتركه
تقترح اجراء استفتاء شعبي على قانون
التقاعد
من امام مقر المجلس الدستوري في باريس
معنى مراسل الجزيره حافظ مربح حافظ هل
هناك اي مؤشرات او
الترجيحات لما يمكن ان يخرج به المجلس
الدستوري بشان هذه القضيه المثيره للجدل
في باريس
حسن في الحقيقه الجميع هنا ينتظر ما سيصدر
عن المجلس الدستوري في حدود الساعه
السابعه مساء بتوقيت الدوحه السادسه
بتوقيت باريس لا احد يعلم في الحقيقه قرار
المجلس الدستوري الذي بحثته وتمت مداولته
خلال الشهر الماضي تقريبا واحيط الامر
بالسريه الكل هنا في فرنسا ينتظر هذا
القرار لا سيما وان البلاد تشهد توترا
اجتماعيا وحتى سياسيا على خلفيه رفض طيف
واسع من الفرنسيين سواء من النقابات او من
الناشطين السياسيين والاحزاب او حتى
المواطنين رفضهم
بانظمه التقاعد الذي سيرفع في انظمه
التقاعد نعم للاشاره ما ذكرته عن هذا
الرفض انما يتمثل
بالمظاهرات المستمره التي شهدناها بالامس
ونشدها
في هذه اللحظات هذه ايضا مظاهره حاشده
وانت ايضا معنا على الهواء من امام المجلس
الدستوري بانتظار صدور قرار المجلس
الدستوري مظاهره في هذه اللحظات في
العاصمه باريس مظاهره حاشده ايضا رافضه
لمشروع قانون التقاعد كنت تحدثنا عن هذا
الرفض حافظ
نعم في الحقيقه هذا الرفض يتجلى في 12
يوما من التحركات منذ ثلاثه اشهر تقريبا
ضد هذا القانون الذي سيرفع في سن التقاعد
من 68 الى 64 عاما لعل يوم امس شهدنا
المظاهرات سواء في باريس او في مدن اخرى
النقابات قدرتها بنحو مليون ونصف متظاهر
في حين قالت السلطات انه نحو 400 الف
متظاهر خرجوا في شوارع فرنسا اليوم مثلا
هذه المظاهره التي نبث صورها في هذه
الاثناء هي لطلبه وتلاميذ في باريس يتجهون
لكي يشاركوا في المظاهره اخرى مقرره قربه
بلديه باريس مساء اليوم
ردا على مشروع الحكومه ليستحي انظمه
التقاعد وهذا القانون المثير
للجدل في الحقيقه النقابات تعول على بقاء
الشارع حيا وبقاء هذه تحركات وهي تحشم
لتحرك كبير مثلا يوم واحد ما المقبل خاصه
وانها تسعى جاهده
لكي تنسق جهودها ضد هذا المشروع يوم امس
مساء مثلا القاده النقابيون
اجتمعوا لكي ينسقوا مواقفهم وكيف سيكون
عملهم في المرحله المقبله ثم شبه اجماع
لدى النقابات العماليه مثلا ان التحركات
لا يجب ان تتوقف تم دعوات اطلقها بعض
القياديين النقابيين للرئيس ماكرون مثلا
ودعوه فيها حتى ان كان المجلس الدستوري قد
اقر في قراره بدستوريه هذا القانون دعه
الرئيس ماكرون الى عدم توقيعه وتوقيع هذا
القانون هو اخر مراحل دخوله حيز التنفيذ
تقريبا يعني هنالك رفض ما زال قائما في
شارع الفرنسي في الساحه السياسيه الفرنسيه
هذا القانون سواء برمته او حتى بعض بنوده
لان ذلك سيمكنها من التجريف في هذا
القانون والدعوه الى عدم تنفيذه نعم
موعد مرجح لصدور قرار المجلس الدستوري
يعني ساعه محدده
[موسيقى]
نعم هذا القرار سيصدر في حدود الساعه
السابعه مساء بتوقيت الدوحه وسيكون في شكل
بيان بحسب اخر الاخبار التي وردتنا من
المجلس الدستوري ولكن تجدر الاشاره الى ان
السلطات اتخذت عده تدابير امنيه منذ يوم
امس وحتى يوم السبت صباحا مثلا منعت اي
تجمع للمواطنين او تظاهر في محيط المجلس
هنا في المجلس كما تشاهدون خلفي تمت
تعزيزات امنيه ايضا حمايه وتطويق لكل
المجلس راينا حتى رجال شرطه فوق سطح
المجلس تحسبا لاي اعمال احتجاجيه او اعمال
شغب او ما شابه ذلك نعم شكرا جزيلا لكنت
معنا من امام المجلس مقر المجلس الدستوري